[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the consultant editor of the daily mail
andrew pearce and the associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire a
shortened pay-per-review because of our
extended news at 10 but you will be with
us till midnight so good to see you both
so let's take a look then what's making
the front pages and most of the papers
are leading on the attack on a maternity
hospital in mariopol
putin bombs children's hospital is the
headline for the eye
the metro describes it as a new low for
putin with a picture of some of those
injured
the mirror says simply barbaric
while the male calls it depraved and
says boris johnson has vowed to hold
president putin to account
president zielenski says russia has
committed an atrocity and that there are
children buried under the rubble that
makes the front of the ft
the daily telegraph reports that there
are concerns in the west that putin is
planning a chemical attack
and the yorkshire post says boris
johnson is resisting calls from within
his own party to relax visa requirements
for ukrainian refugees
and just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you can see on screen
during the program you can check out
those front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us
so let's bring in andrew pierce and
kevin mcguire then and um
some shocking front pages after some
shocking news kevin let's start with
your paper the daily mirror
the headline there barbaric um with this
horrendous
air strike on on a hospital perhaps some
of the more shocking scenes in a
fortnight of horrors
yeah
and i just when you think you can't be
shocked anymore you you are and this is
the hospital in mariopol the maternity
hospital children's hospital utterly
devastated and that picture widely seen
now of a very heavily pregnant woman
possibly just about to be given uh give
birth being carried out uh because it's
been uh it's been uh wrecked and uh
barbaric who could disagree that he is
barbaric whether it was intentionally
targeted bomb or not if you're dropping
bombs on a uh the port city of mario
paul 460 000 people in it they're
trapped
uh it's got to be a war crime because
you're going to just be killing innocent
uh civilians you can't use the old
excuses putin's apologists will
that it's a military target it's not
it's it's terrorizing a civilian
population and trying to beat them uh
into uh in in the submission so they
will surrender the
ukrainians are showing in remarkable
inspiring defiance and uh and brazilians
but there you see the picture there that
woman hugging that child it is
a young soldier it doesn't really look
old enough to be wearing a uniform uh
bandaging people and then look at the
size of the crater we just saw as well
what type of weapon would you use to
make a hole in the ground that big and
everything that is thrown up causes
utter devastation it is uh it's
utterly utterly appalling
and the front page of your paper andrew
and the daily mail depraved that's from
what boris johnson's um
how he described it wasn't it and they
also say that the prime minister is
talking about holding putin to account
for his terrible crimes
do you think that
an atrocity like this could be some kind
of turning point in how the nato
countries approach this conflict
uh
you'd like to i don't think it is really
anna because what what the ukrainians
want desperately more than anything is
the no-fly zone to be enforced over
ukraine and that's there's simply no
wiggle room on that at all no compromise
britain's not up for it nor is the
united states no nato country is we're
even concerned about these
soldiers who are deserting their uh
their ranks in britain to go and fight
in ukraine because we don't want to be
seen to be uh british troops involved in
a war with with russia um but this but
when boris johnson said he's going to
hold him to account look how do you hold
vladimir putin took out he doesn't care
he couldn't care less what people think
about him there is of course there is no
statute of limitations on war crimes so
perhaps one day they will get him
in in a trial but i think by i hope long
before that happens somebody's taking
him out with a bullet in his head which
is the very least he deserves uh it is
shocking um i think we're getting to the
point now where nothing
more that putin can do could shock us
but he managed it today didn't he a
maternity hospital kevin's quite right
the scale of that crater in front of the
hospital what on earth were they
thinking of why did they send a bomb
that big to target a hospital and i
think he did it deliberately i don't
think it's an accident uh i think it is
designed to put the fear of god into
those people in maripo it's been
bombarded now for days on days on days
the the civil uh the the the the process
by which people were supposed to be able
to be evacuated the russians have bombed
them the whole way through it they are
going through a living hell in maripole
and uh
it's beyond unspeakable and if we look
at the front page of the eye kevin they
have in one of their bullet points
underneath the main headline at the
ukrainian president asking how much
longer will the world be an accomplice
ignoring terror in an interview with at
sky news tonight he said that
millions of people
could die
if they don't close the skies but
do you do you agree that it is a very
delicate decision that the uk wants to
support
ukraine as much as possible by sending
weapons but doesn't want to tip this
into a wider war and escalate matters is
that a is that an understandable
position
it is anna and uh britain and germany
and the us and other countries that are
sending weapons want to
close the skies with
the ukrainians using
ground to air missiles to bring down
russian aircraft and helicopters doing
it that way rather than
flying in
uh aircraft that would would result
inevitably in a military confrontation
which would escalate uh the conflict and
it would spread it and could lead to
more dying even if nuclear weapons
aren't used i i understand uh zelensky's
uh anger and frustration and
sitting safely uh 1500 miles away uh
i i can appreciate it he was he was
rather tactful in his address to mps and
peers in parliament where he he talked
of the disappointment uh
where that uh the skies weren't being
closed but we we saw the complications
with the
polls wanting to send to germany for the
us to deliver soviet era mig-29 aircraft
rather than do it themselves because
because they're they're very close uh uh
to russia and they fear the fear the
consequences so there i i understand uh
yeah i'm
on this i'm with the generals rather
than the armchair generals who
appreciate how we could uh how we could
spread very rapidly if all of a sudden
you say right the raf and others are
going to enforce a north fly zone what
happens when they're shot at from the
ground or in the air then you have to
engage and missiles could be fired from
russia so then do you
go back into russian territory and it
and it escalates that's probably no
comfort at all to the the poor souls in
uh mario paul in other other cities but
there's a kind of terrible terrible grim
reality to it
the front of the daily telegraph has uh
the same picture andrew that a lot of
the papers have featured of that
pregnant woman being carried out of the
hospital but their headline says russia
plotting chemical attack um quoting
officials who are saying that they're
concerned that putin may be frustrated
at his lack of progress so far in
ukraine and might
resort to more extreme measures
yeah and what they're doing it because
we know putin is a master of propaganda
and black propaganda and the state media
in russia is uh putin is controlled by
putin they keep running stories in
russia saying that ukraine is planning
chemical attacks on russia so that's why
this the the terrible suspicion is now
that that's what he's in fact planning
to do
to to ukraine he will say it's
self-defense it's uh he's been provoked
it's it's he did they've done it in
syria uh he uses whatever means possible
to try to uh enforce his will but we
know the conventional warfare is not
working for him there were some very
graphic images on sky earlier tonight of
that tank convoy that had been laid to
waste by british uh missiles so and that
great convoy that's trying to head for
kiev is still not any closer so that's
why increasingly he's having to resort
to the tried and tested way of puting
bombardment and horribly terror
potentially chemical warfare too which
would be another war crime but still i
don't think it would change anything
about the no-fly zone
um and a very quick word um kevin we're
going to talk about this a little bit
more in the 11 o'clock hour but very
briefly inside the metro of course the
humanitarian crisis continues the
headline in the metro we're giving up on
britain's say refugees
yeah i think it's it's utterly shameless
the uh the bureaucratic callous uh
inertia of the system with
fewer than uh one thousand uh accepted
into uh the uk up to two million
refugees uh now families are giving up
now at calais uh and pretty patel the
home secretary has not caught herself in
glorious criticism from conservative uh
mps as well as as labor and
the public
okay and we will explore that a little
bit further at 11 and you are staying
with us until about quarter to 12. so um
for the moment both of you thanks very
much indeed and we'll see you shortly